was in those kind of societies where I
can really appreciate him where even
though yes it's never there's never
going to be complete equality so even
though there are um it can be really
terrible for men but at the same time I
do feel like this is the best of both do
you think do you think women should be
heavily questioned though if they're
accusing someone of something that
serious where they should be questioned
on everything it's not saying like you
deserve it but it's maybe questioning
the person's credibility I think on a
personal one-to-one level
um I wouldn't necessarily have any
heavily question like we're talking
about the law in terms of yeah if it's a
public thing and it's going to court yes
I think it's innocent until proven
guilty so
um but if if someone came to you
personally I wouldn't go about oh are
you sure this happened I think you
should just take it on board and try and
um you know take it to the right
authorities I think I think when you
when you say that you know I understand
what you're saying but don't you think
you're saying it's better this way
because it suits you so I've been in a
situation where someone said oh he's
done this but then when you question a
bit you find out actually no nothing
none of that happened and she just said
that because she didn't want to feel as
though she was a you know three or four
or whatever right so don't you think
that what you're saying is is better
it's just a situation that benefits you
and actually in a society where we
question people when they make
accusations where the consequences of
those accusations being true are very
very deep consequences negative
consequences isn't it better that we you
know look into it and see okay is this
true
yeah to answer your second question yes
it is better to obviously investigate
and I feel like that's where this is
just like a backlash obviously like an
over correction of the things that went
wrong in the past however because I've
like experienced both I won't
necessarily say it's better just because
I'm a woman obviously that is a factor
to it but I also feel like it's just not
um productive for Society for women to
be like harassed constantly by men like
it just I've had even situations where a
bus driver has followed me like in the
bus with people in the bus
them uncles can be different but like I
don't what I mean is you know the people
that question you when you come to them
and tell them yeah isn't it better for
to live in a society where people are
questioned because the consequences are
that because even if it's just in
personal life like that's character
assassination so men every day can have
their character assassinated around
campus and in their communities and the
women aren't questioned at all all yeah
exactly like I mean if I was a woman and
some some a man went to court for
something like he was accused for
something even if it was if he came out
innocent I would not be with him if I
was an employer I would not hire him
because you never know that person's
character and personality but not
Personality yeah
that person is pretty much rude for me
so um question do women have a right to
be afraid of men when 80 of violent
crime is done by men
do women have a right to be afraid of
men because 80 percent of violent crime
is done by men I think they'd be smart
to be
um scared of men because I know for
facts about the door right now I tell
her be careful when you're walking on
the streets for a random men you know I
think it's it's better better to be you
know safe than sorry
um but obviously most
it's when people say that they feel
unsafe feeling unsafe and actually being
unsafe for two different things because
men tend to be the ones that um are the
victims of violent crime the most so
it's it's a balance what about you guys
I would say be aware
um that
the stat is what it is but I wouldn't
say
like
every day oh as soon as you walk out
your door 80 of men are dangerous and
walk in that fear because you're not
going you're going to assume every man
is going to attack you or do something
to you because you have that stat like
be aware but still like live your life
and
act accordingly don't be stupid and
naive and go out at night and go down a
dark alleyway and put yourself into a
position for something to happen just
but just be aware that's what I would
say
yeah I think that um
What creatures are routine so if you're
going through the same areas same
neighborhoods like going from work or
wherever it is that you're going over
time you're gonna feel safe I mean
you're not you know if you don't if
you're doing though keeping it simple in
that sense like even me
moving to the Aki to get used to like
you know how like the street lights
don't light up the sidewalk like the
pavement you know so I'll be walking in
the street because they're better lit
because I don't know who's like looking
in the dark under so I think we all
should just put ourselves in safer
situations and we're less likely to be
you know worried male or female so yeah
I think the problem is like there's not
too much of a distinction between what
it is to be a man and what it is to be a
woman and so that has sort of like
erased women's fear because Society is
just telling us like we're exactly the
same and we're not so I think that fear
is actually very beneficial for women
and um so you do think that we should be
afraid of man like to some extent I'm
just clarifying yes yes because they're
different okay yeah what about you guys
I think um I think it's a difference
between men and women because men will
always be afraid of other men
we may not fear men but we recognize the
threat always
so my job as a father of a daughter is
to teach her that she needs to cultivate
this type of awareness it's not a fear
it's an awareness it's an awareness that
at any moment when I'm dealing with a
man
if things go sideways I could get very
physically damaged and just accepting
that and then operating from that and
and having the mental health in order to
not allow it to turn into paranoia and
keep it in something that produces
protection self-protection and not like
just freaking out
yeah same I think they need to be aware
um not fear
aware for sure but the thing is like
women menstrual can be the scariest
thing to a woman but they can also be
the um
what's the opposite of scary
fuzzy yeah not scary protection yeah
they can protect women as well
um and I wanted to ask did do your
parents ladies did your parents ever
tell you to fear men
no no no no no okay so so just just
follow-up question
how is that different than fearing
certain races because of statistical
data
so if we flip this conversation and
insert it as a race yeah you would think
that's fine I don't necessarily think
it's a bad thing but okay it's just
spicy I like it interesting I think one
can be racist and or sexist and not be
both so I think it's possible to
understand the dangers of a male versus
female and not be racist
I also think that some people could say
do you mean sexist or I'm sorry yeah
sorry sorry
um so I also think that some people
could be worried about other races
having
relations with their women like is often
the argument that gets put out there
because of their build because of their
physique whatever
and
maybe there's a point to that I mean